hey everybody this is International
master David proofs for chest comm and
today we are going to see a very classic
Morphy game it's a pretty famous one so
if you are already a serious student of
chess you may already have seen it what
I want you to look for in this game is I
want you to look for four things which
more if he does extremely well and which
you're supposed to learn from this game
number one is how to seize the
initiative in the opening number two is
how to develop quickly
number three is how to open the game and
number four is how to attack the enemy
king down an open file in the center now
I'm also going to do another video on
that topic so you'll see another sample
game along the same lines for that
fourth part attacking down an open file
that's under chess strategy but this is
a fundamental and important thing so
it's great to see it more than once this
Morphy game is quite sweet so let's get
it started shall we
morphia is playing black here and his
opponent plays f4 and we have a video on
the King's gambit which points out that
one of the good things about the King's
gambit is that it tries to gain control
of the center and one of the bad things
is that it spends a move not developing
a piece on move - so morphe responds to
it with a very aggressive move which is
supposed to emphasize what what does
this move from black emphasize the
answer is development it's not so much
the black is trying to fight back for
control the center actually which is
what you might think is the move is in
the center but no the actual meaning of
this move is that black is trying to
develop quickly here's why I don't think
he's trying to fight for the center with
this move he's allowing white to just
you know capture his his pawns in the
center he's not defending those pawns
he's sacrificing them so he's going to
leave white probably with some
preponderance of pawns in the center but
what that move does is it lets his
Bishop out so really he's trying to
create a scenario where white might get
a better position in the center by
capturing his pawns but he's letting his
pieces come out quite quickly okay so
white takes this pawn which was the best
move and black plays eform and this move
is designed to prevent whites most
important development of putting a
knight on f3 which would defend against
Queen h4 check
and help white to get his King Castle
kingside so white is immediately going
to challenge this pawn and fight for it
so this becomes the key square on the
board Knight c3 Knight f6 and now d3
attacking the pawn more so morphe does a
very good job here of developing in a
very powerful way right every
development move is fighting for the key
square and putting pressure on white and
now white plays Bishop d2 and having
blocked this diagonal there's some
danger that white is going to win
control over the e4 square so morphe
deftly switches the focus of the game
which is very clever and this next move
is a very very good example of how you
can seize the initiative in the opening
he plays this pawn forward to e3
sacrificing another pawn but that leaves
this pawn here which means this bishop
is blocked in right and it also means
that when this pawn is gone this file is
going to be open so obviously his follow
up after Bishop takes pawn is castles
King side I mean I shouldn't say too
obviously because Knight takes pawn is
also a decent-looking move right putting
pressure on c3 attacking the bishop and
regaining one pawn but more fees not in
a hurry to win back upon he knows he'll
be able to and after Bishop d2 which is
the best defensive move he's going to
have the chance to attack down this open
E file so hopefully you've seen how the
first couple moves of this game morphe
has done a great job of seizing the
initiative he's forced white to consume
some time with some pawn sacks but he's
not in danger of being down too much and
he's really developed his game very very
quickly but now what you're going to see
is he needs to develop an attack from
this position here so far white has
brought out two pieces and he has
brought out two pieces plus castling so
white hasn't fallen too too far behind
in development but he's created a
scenario where white couldn't get this
Bishop out very well couldn't bring this
Knight out before because of the pawn
here so he's going to try and keep that
going so the first thing he does is very
important he makes a piece trade here on
c3 a lot of people think that
you're attacking you don't really want
to trade pieces you want lots of pieces
on the board to make threats with but
what more if he didn't like was that if
he plays rook check white might bring
the knight back this way when there will
probably be a trade of these bishops and
now the e2 square is defended very well
and white is looking at some position
like this and maybe quickly castling
queenside or at least bringing out his
pieces so morphe actually makes a great
decision here and instead of giving the
check he just trades on c3 first so
white takes back with the pawn so that
his bishop remains defending these two
squares and isn't in range of the night
when the night comes to d5 and now rook
e8 check Bishop e2 now war if he could
regain a pawn here and he would have a
really good position objectively
speaking Knight takes d5 is just as good
as the move he played but with the move
he played you see again more fees kind
of focused on trying to make it hard for
white to develop his point is that white
can't bring out this knight now because
he'll take on f3 I will have to take
with the pawn because his bishop can't
move and now the white king is in
serious danger he'll play this move and
he's thinking of Queen to h4 check right
and basically White's position is sort
of structurally shattered it's hard for
him to move these pieces both his
bishops are shut in by his weird pawn
structure and this is hard for him to
coordinate for a defense of his King the
attack gets started pretty fast there so
Bishop c4 is a very nice move and in
response white plays a really bad move
c4 trying to keep his second extra pawn
on d5 the best move for white is a
hundred percent absolutely h3 just so
you can learn a little defense here you
have to attack the Bishop trying to
force it to take on me too so that you
can bring out your knight from the back
rank okay absolutely a forced move here
for white this move h3 but c4 is played
absolutely the wrong idea right trying
to stay ahead two pawns uh when your
opponent is already in a position where
they're putting serious pressure against
your King and how
an open file but it's not that easy to
win for black here and more if he shows
an important technique here so how would
you try to win this position as black
how would you try and build your attack
along the open e file well the answer is
the e file by itself is not a
sufficiently wide opening of the
position for you to take your army come
through the board and come checkmate
this king with this many white pieces
around him
okay White's development isn't good but
the positions not sufficiently open that
this black rook and Knight have a way to
help black breakthrough on e2 right now
so if you just tried to bang your head
into e2 with every piece you have you
actually wouldn't get through white
would play Age 3 now you would take and
he would take with his knight and then
he would play as King to f2 and his rook
to e1 and he might survive and he's
still up to pawns so there is some onus
on you whenever you sacrifice material
to play very very accurate moves
thereafter so very important move from
black here this technique to play c6 and
this move threatens to take back one of
the two pawns black is behind and more
importantly it's just trying to get a
bunch of pawns out of the way in the
center of the board to increase the
possible attacking scope of blacks
pieces so now another bad move from
white pawn takes c6 what move do you
think white should play if you said h3
you got it white has to find a way to
get this night out okay absolutely
necessary he can't just sit with his
King on e1 forever like a sitting duck
you know back in more fees day as I've
mentioned before the level of opposition
was essentially non-existent people just
you know didn't know any principles yet
um just like beginners right because the
whole world of chess just didn't know
that much yet and morphe was introducing
these kind of ideas for the first time
and out comes his piece right
thank you very much white and now the
threat is Knight d4 and only here does
white realize that he's losing and you
know basically in one move to black just
playing 94 and capturing on e2 so white
uh played King f1 so that he can answer
94 with Bishop takes
you four more if he found a crushing
move here which I at the time was
perhaps a revelation but now pretty much
anyone should be able to find
nevertheless a cool breakthrough idea so
any beginners watching won't won't know
this yet what should black do here to
break through and win on e - after white
side steps the answer is white still has
a possible pin along the diagonal even
if not along the file so what you want
to do is you want to keep your Bishop on
g4 but you don't want white to have a
bishop which can take on g4 you replace
his Bishop on e2 with another piece
right which can't capture your bishop
and then you gang up on this piece here
and with that rook sac he immediately
recovers a second piece and so actually
it's winning material for black the
White Queen ran away to avoid being lost
after Bishop takes e to right which
would attack the Queen and King so the
Queen moves away black takes and now
black is just going to finish off this
poor King notice the power of the white
rooks being undeveloped and more if he
calculated very precisely here so this
is you know impressive calculation that
he saw this Knight f3 check would lead
to a forced checkmate in several moves
more if it was already a pretty good
calculator on Knight comes back to h6
and white has no defense against Knight
f5 Queen g4 type-check mates he defended
the g4 squaring more if you played
Knight f5 check King g5 and checkmate
boom absolute massacre but you can
definitely learn four important things
from it if you've already forgotten what
they are I'm not repeating it just go
back to the beginning of the video I
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you around on chess calm